let's talk about your song let's talk
about your new favorite song by car to
be called whap
why do you like it so much adam tell the
rest of us why you like this
wet ass you know this song so much what
is
pussycat um well do you want the truth
or do you want me to make up something
no no we want this so
the truth is i didn't hear about this
song until yesterday when you brought it
up i know i
wait a minute i did not bring you you
brought it up josh
josh loves let's clarify i brought it up
because i think it is
the absolute most degradating stupid
as9 song in the world um obviously josh
uh
uh let's just to put it mildly is not
the hip-hop crowd
if you will it's not who they're going
after no no they're not maybe mace in
who's to say i'm not part of the hip hop
you're not that they've already ruled
against you bro
let's not even play that card all right
you're not part of that crew are you
telling me that i can't freestyle
i'm telling you can freestyle actually
but that you're not going to be any part
of hip-hop crew anymore anytime soon
however um as a hip-hop fan
not even as a someone who's judging
culture
or anything or a conservative voice
this is just an actual horrible song and
but so if i'm cardi b
i got maybe like a five year window for
me to make all my money she's probably
on the tail end of twenties right now
she's implants everywhere fake as hell
her career is not gonna she's not gonna
be a 45 year old female rapper
that doesn't happen like little kim's
been gone for 20 years right from the
scene
so cardi b's got maybe five more years
five more years of
going all in on her ass and titties and
everything that she's got going on her
whole brand of being a dirty [ __ ]
with a wap um she's got five years to
make uh
these disgusting songs and make hits and
you know
get her cash and then she's out because
she's not gonna she ain't running for
president anytime soon
so so go ahead let me tell you what i
hate about it
i hate the fact that martin luther king
the man the myth the legend had to stand
up and give
his life for what the advancement of
this
like to me this is one of the worst
things not just to happen
to music but to happen to the
african-american community
when these are the people that are the
role models that are perpetrated upon
the young people when this is the
message
i remember martin luther king saying i
would that one day
my four children would not be based upon
the color of their skin
but on the content of their character
when i
when i read the lyrics to this song what
kind of character
are we parading in front of kids
uh today and particularly women we've
been talking about
empowering women how does this empower
women this literally objects
objectifies them sexualizes them
degrades them
demoralizes them what is it about this
is this something
not i don't i realize you don't have a
daughter at least that you know about
yet but one
day you probably will and i'll tell you
this adam when you watch
stuff like this when you watch stuff
like big mouth and all this other bull
crap
and you realize that this is a look pat
this is why valuetainment's important
this is why people as we start rolling
out content over
over the next year for kids and all this
stuff this is why people need to make
sure that their
kids are glued to channels like
valuetainment because if not
as a man think if it's not just bible
people of course like
as a man thinks so is he so when you are
listening to stuff and you're plugging
those ipod
uh those airpods into your flipping kids
ears
and they're taking in all this stuff
what they hear is what they think what
they think
is what they flip and become and
honestly i think that if we want to know
who's responsible for the
the crime rate and all this stuff why
don't people start boycotting
these idiots the jay-z's do you want
them to boycott exactly
i want them to boycott stupid music that
puts the wrong values
in particularly they give you you want
them to boycott free speech
i'm saying that's the beauty that's a
beautiful thing about free speech bro
is that free speech i'm not saying she
doesn't have a right to say it
i'm saying that people should be smart
enough to unionize
as individuals think that cardi b has a
w.a.p
i think that cardi b is a stupid
idiot is what i think point is
i think she may have a wap
but she probably has a hundred s twenty
second delay
yeah oh my god ketchup um
they should call the song std because
let's be honest
that's exactly what she's full of yeah
she's a former stripper i mean listen
this is
this is par for the course with this
lady she's a former stripper who made
her money
on being a ho and she's just embracing
that whole life
and she's you know claiming that it's
female empowerment i do what i want with
my body it's all
more power to you ho however uh the the
song within itself is is pretty trashy
uh but free speech with this kylie
jenner showed up
in the video they're marketers man
whatever they do just know they're
looking at marketing
let me give my thoughts on this yeah
here's what i think about this okay this
is this is the question i
asked jen this morning i said jen
what do you think about this song 20
seconds she stops it i said
what do you think about it it says i
hate it i said
when you were 18 did you listen to the
song she says no
i said okay all right let's say she
didn't listen to it
then i went back and i said when i was
18 did i listen to the song
okay and i'm talking about that because
this you only know the 41 euro pad you
don't know the 22 year old pattern the
25 year old pet you only know the 41
year old pet
so then i said what songs do i know the
lyrics off
right off the top of my head okay three
six mafia slop
i'm not like corn on the cop check in
with me
and then do your job lay on the bed yang
give me a hand
no questions asked no time to beg right
like i can't believe i know this yeah
dirty ass song then i'm like okay uh
you're good look at you now
do it do it do it right look get good
just like you should
then i go back and i say one of my
favorite rap songs of all time was mc
light
you know to me most people don't know
him she like keep on keep keeping on
like
don't only the strong survive only the
wise excel you know she talks about the
whole thing she's talking about come get
it
i pick i choose get in between you know
she's just talking pure dirty that i
pick and choose and if you do your job
right
i'll let you do it again and again and
again and again mclight you know what
mcleigh does today she's a pastor
okay mcleod yeah m.c light is a pastor
today okay so where am i going with this
okay back in the days the song that
started like this
that became a big hit you ready we're
not against
rap we're not against rappers
but we are against those thugs
okay you know that you're still look at
the look on his face it's the darkest
ruggish bro
okay okay so so so here's
that here's the point doesn't harm
that's why you don't listen
hold on i know crossroads okay yeah
that's good
of course you know something with the
word cross in it obviously hello
but let me tell you but let me let me
tell you what angle i'm taking with this
here's the angle i'm taking with this i
sat there
and i and i have this thing that i
pulled up 45 communist goals 1958
written by cleon skousen on how to
change the one country that's the most
powerful country in the world
that exposed everybody else to prove
that capitalism works and all the other
people that hate capitalism have been
pissed off by it
i sent a tweet the other day that ticked
off a bunch of different people when i
said
you know people ask me why there's a
love-hate relationship with capitalism
and i responded until right now
people are still commenting to it
comments it's got like 7 400 likes 1800
retweets i've never had anything yet
i mean i've got a couple things with
other videos but nothing got this kind
of attraction
capitalism works for those who work take
initiative and constantly look for ways
to improve themselves
capitalism sucks for those who are lazy
lack initiative
and stop learning after finishing school
and next thing you know
you are such a greedy section and just
went off on me no problem capitalism
exposes us
very simple right okay 45 communist
goals of 1958.
watch the angle i'm going to we don't
are we done with the hip-hop i'm not
it's no i'm on it
okay because i had a point wait here's
where i'm going with this check this out
45 points this is written in 1958
by cleon skousen a 15-year cia agent
you ready here's one of them
break down cultural standards of
morality by promoting pornography and
obscenity in books magazines motion
pictures radio and
music and tv okay no problem
so for me when i got out of the army and
i started working at bellies
i had a foul mouth and when i say foul
mouth i don't mean like a foul mouth i
had a
maybe the worst you've ever seen in your
life really more than anybody else
you've ever seen i mean i was terry you
were talking about wilbon yesterday yeah
i was terrible i was terrible one day a
guy named fernando lasso sits me down
and says hey can i ask you a question
good friend of mine ended up being one
of my groomsmen at my wedding he's in
ecuador right now
he says why do you curse so much he's a
christian guy
i said what do you mean i said i was in
the military says it's too much
you're just nonce he can't even help you
do you know how much you curse
he says i'm gonna tell you moving
forward how much you curse and he starts
putting the numbers
yeah he says you gotta work on that
shout out to gary v he says it's just
too much
okay so to me i started kind of working
on that and trying to change my language
what's the point here here's the point
let me tell you just the fact that those
words are in my mind
slop you know all just i'm like this
works
the programming works when i
sit there at them and i try to work on
somebody to change their lives
the first thing i work on is the
identity in the middle then i work on
your language
if your language doesn't change done
so when i watch a a couple you know i
can name a bunch of people and i watch
them go from making a 50k
income to making a million dollar your
income from running a 100 000
your business to a 20 million dollar
business what changes
is the identity on the inside the values
and principles on the inside and then
the language
totally and then the language once the
language changes
everything changes so to me yes this
kind of music can ruin
an 18 year old kid's life if it gets
into them
and if a person that's got big dreams
and wants to shift it has to change
their values and principles and these
values and principles
are not helping america you want to go i
guess i gotta
you got a hip-hop comment well yeah yeah
so what do you do
in order to make that lane that language
catchy
we do it all the way from from preschool
if you want to teach kids
how to talk if you want to teach them a
song abc's
a b c d e like
you put a tune to it and you start
changing their language because they
enjoy
the instrumentation the vocalization of
the song
but really what they're doing is
flipping programming it is programming
well i think you know something that we
talk about here
often is the riches are in the niches
right okay so
and it also comes down to who do you
want to be something that will always
come back
something that you yes so i used to do
stand-up comedy and i used to do a bit
there's a two-part story here with
some with comedy and stuff with music i
used to do stand-up comedy
and my two biggest inspirations for
comedy
were the deaf comedy jam and jerry
seinfeld so i used to do a bit where i
used to be like what would it sound like
if
jerry frickin seinfeld who doesn't curse
at all went on the deaf comedy jam where
it's
all about cursing and he would just be
like so what's the deal with all these
[ __ ] hoes i mean come on
so i used to do a bit like that but um
seinfeld doesn't curse one of the
greatest comedians ever
dave chappelle and certain other
comedians cursed like crazy
are also one of the greatest comedians
ever so who do you want to be you talked
about mc light there's another rapper
that came to mind
uh queen latifah probably even bigger
than mc light back in the day
two of the biggest female rappers what
was her hit song back in the day do you
remember
which one again queen latifah what was
her hit uh
unity
all right so cool she never sang about
her wet ass
or being a hoe or slobbing on the knob
her
niche in the riches was all about unity
and look at her now she's a big time
actress
she's on the cover of magazines mclight
pastor so let's take it back to the who
does cardi b want to be
cardi b wants to be the queen of the
hose
make no mistake about it she wants to be
the whole queen so she's playing that
role
she's not trying to be a politician just
like there's different rappers okay
jay-z these days is a lot different like
you just said when pat was 20 versus
when he's 40.
jay-z's a lot different now than when he
when when he was 20. so there's also
difference you can't just say hip-hop's
bad rap sucks
they're certain no i'm not saying that
i'm not but i'm just saying there's
rappers like j
cole who are conscious rappers who are
using lyrics and and
so and doing stuff like that and then
you got things like migos who are
shout out to that's cardi b's husband
who are like
[ __ ] there's [ __ ] that
[ __ ] so it's who do you want to
be
so it's not just one broad stroke but
and that's my point allow me to respond
to you and maybe a couple of the uh
valuetainers so when i'm talking about
stuff like jay-z
okay i'm saying this when you have
guys now i'm not saying he doesn't make
incredible music i mean
i mean the dude's like he's a dope were
you about to float were you about the
floor right there what was that no
so let the cat out the back buddy but
but
i'm saying they are responsible for the
messaging
that they're giving the young black
community which is traditionally hip-hop
do you have a responsibility why do
white kids listen to hypocrites okay
okay but so so so look if if you're a
cultural icon
you have a responsibility not to be
talking about yo i got here because i
slain yeah yo on the corner i gotta
sling a rock i got you know like
what what do you have a cultural
responsibility you have a responsibility
according to who
i'm saying is that if you're going to be
a leader and we're
we're going and we're telling kids to
look up to you as a parent
you should be telling a kid who's
telling them that they need to be a
leader or a parent
look up to them is what i'm saying
that's what you're saying no i'm not
saying
rapper be my leader i'm just saying make
that song dude okay
so what i'm what i'm saying is this is a
parent has a responsibility
to monitor the messaging you're not just
a babysitter
i'm saying a hundred percent okay the
parent should say uh no
jay-z is a loser and he's making a bunch
of money
selling a message of sex drugs and and
of
shooting the cops so that's not what
jesus
and by the way here's the thing charles
barkley said it best i'm not a role
model so he didn't want to be a role
model some of these guys don't want to
be role models some of them do
what i do think is the fact that it is
hurting people it will get into your
mind it will change your language and it
will show up in your day-to-day work
and mindset it's that simple it'll
create range anger if you listen to it
you ask me a question what song i listen
to at work out and i told you what's up
because it creates rage because i want
to hit the weights like mario listens to
heavy metal and kind of stuff i would
never listen to but it works for him
but i just think you have to be very
aware of it because it is going to
affect you